so so here's a guy far leftist they
didn't care about his his
his goings on in in seattle complete
there were a lot of other people
has anybody been arrested over the
murders no
i got a story for abc news prosecutors
drop case against a man
charged in capital riot federal
prosecutors have dropped the criminal
case against a new york man who was
accused of participating in the right at
the u.s capitol
the fbi went and arrested a man
because my understanding is a paid
informant this told
the fbi he was in the capital and they
said
good enough for us went arrested him
turns out
he wasn't phone evidence apparently
proves he wasn't they never had evidence
yet they're going to go and track this
guy down on the ward of some random
nobody
but these antifa extremists nothing on
this one i
did you actually pull up the charging
documents on that no oh so i actually
went into that earlier today and i was
looking at it first as a story for human
events
um we're still probably going to do it
but i want it i want to give it to it
justice but
since you brought it up i'll mention it
this paid informant
sounds like and again it's they're very
vague about it because they're
they're trying very hard to make sure
that you know they're not revealing
their source on this
he was in a facebook group chat
and it appears that he was in the group
chat
prior to january 6 that he was
already there so just taking that
information
as it is you're looking at a capability
you're looking at a tactic the fbi is
using
they are paying people to go into
facebook group chats
and keep track of what's going on in
there yep and and so the question then
becomes
as you're looking through there now
again they're not showing the actual
messages
in this chat because i think that might
reveal who it is they're just referring
to the messages
so it becomes very hard to tell whether
the guy they're talking about is the one
who
actually went in or whether it's
somebody else who was in the group chat
because
even i remember having been you know in
in the capital on not excuse me not in
the capital in dc
on january 6 um but being in that area i
was across the street at the one of our
canoe studios
cell service was down right you could
not get access anywhere so it would be
very
uh very interesting for me to to hear
that somebody was in the capital and
able to post
into a facebook group chat in real time
right right that almost to me makes it
sound like he
wasn't in the capital because i was
having to make phone calls from the side
of the street to people who were outside
the area with
access to be able to tell me what was
actually happening inside is that the
first time this has happened
we had the story of women in alaska yep
she she posted a photo outside wearing
that was an informant that was that was
something else that was the fed's just
being like we got her
and then arresting the wrong person no
that was if you looked into that
that wasn't the first incident that she
was involved in if you look in terms of
the timeline of when she came across the
radar
she was involved in a mask dispute with
alaska airlines right
right and and that's when the airline
employee it seems like well we don't
know for sure but it seemed like it was
the airline employee
then thinks i want to do something about
this woman i'm
very upset at her so then goes on to
fbi's list of the faces that are pointed
out
and that have all been listed somewhere
and said yeah you look kind of like that
one and
um we're gonna and so i'm gonna send
this to the fbi
and say that you are definitely that
person and so the fbi says hey
we've got the word of an employee
they've identified you this is this is
the person
we're coming and they raided her house
on all this
now by the way going back to you know
i'm not going to say circle back
they're going to do that not going to
use that phrase
thank you jen we love you so much um but
no uh
when it comes to antifa when it comes to
these no-go zones when it comes to the
anti-fascist anarchist terrorism this is
never done right
we we see their faces so many times we
see the live streams
this is never done i got to argue with
you you call them anarchists they're not
anarchists
well they're anarcho-communists they're
not antarctica communists
they're they're tankies they're
authoritarian communists
you get a swath of both yeah but but uh
true anarchy it means without authority
right so left anarchists are like
hippies sitting down stoned and just
not fighting if you if you've actually
ever seen like
i'm sure you know and caps yeah of
course they have the non-aggression
principle
that's a much more well-defined ideology
uh libertarians and end caps
you know it's the free market don't
aggress on me the actual
lefty anarchist because i knew a bunch
at occupied are
were absolutely opposed to fighting with
cops being confrontational
these are the people that would like sit
in circles in the street like sing
kumbaya
because they also agreed with you can't
assert force over someone else that's a
form of authority
what happens is you get these
authoritarian communists
and you know there's there's there's
there's varying degrees of authoritarian
between them the tanki's up in the far
left of the quadrant who are like take
over kill everyone who opposes us right
but then you have some who are like
we'll take it by force it's the only way
none of those people believe in a system
without authority they believe
they are the authority they believe they
have they are the ones who have the
moral authority to determine what is and
and and isn't and they will use physical
violence against you which is the
epitome
of exerting authority against another
person they do however
use the word anarchy to describe
themselves however disguise it
what if they're fighting fascism no no
no no no because
it's not because this is no but i'm
saying this is what they use as sort of
the justification in many of these cases
this goes back to the original antifa
in weimar germany that they're not
anarchy the system is fascism
the uh the police are fascism the
military's fascism banks are fascism the
church is fascinating
those were communists anti-fascists they
specifically called themselves
communists well this is where i say
antarctica communists
but the the the actual
anarcho-communists like
they're lying to you basically i agree
with that yeah they're definitely lying
so
the reason i i i want to i always try to
clarify on what anarchy is because
if these people truly believe
anarcho-communism
is hippies on a farm that's it it
doesn't scale up
there's no you know 10 000
members you know a citizen city that's
not communistic it's impossible
so what ends up happening is the more a
a left anarchist wants to
grow their society the more
authoritarian they naturally become
they call themselves anarchists often
because they're trying to recruit people
into believing they're the peaceful ones
who want to empower you
but they're lying so i don't like using
their language some animals are more
equal than other animals
like if you talk to uh like michael
malus sure he's a huge fan of
of anarchy and anarchism and i'll tell
you what it actually is yeah i actually
um so i just
i got his book as well where i i think
it's actually a
it's like essays on anarchism but it's
it's like a compilation so he wrote some
of it right and then it's other essays
and so we actually cover some similar
topics so we both talk about leon
cholgash
who was the anarchist that killed
mckinley um we talked emma goldman comes
up in both now obviously his head is a
much more in-depth understanding just of
anarchism
but it's interesting that we are both
covering the same thing but i think from
different perspectives
yeah i i view it like you know i've had
long that's just one chapter for me yeah
i've had i've had long discussions with
a lot of people from like occupy wall
street and the leftists
and i'm like you know how do you define
authority right and they typically
will say you know like the people who
control the system the top of the
hierarchy blah blah blah
and then we we inevitably get inevitably
get down to the philosophy of so it
isn't occupying a form of authority
though
uh it depends it depends on so so
obviously you have the power principle
that exists in the in the woke left so
that's what you're talking to
but they typically will say that you
know authority
is you know the people who control the
system and determine
you know what is or isn't and i say how
do they control that system they say
with the police state
with violence and with force and i say
okay so the exertion of physical force
against another person to make them
right do what you want that's authority
and they were like
yes and i said so when you go out and
smash windows and start fires and beat
people
what's the difference you just don't
have the same level of power they do
but you certainly you seem to want it
and you believe in it so this came up
one night when we were at chat
this this whole like lord of lies in
reality
where there was a guy who was accused
of theft remember this and so you know
not to go through that because i mean
there was a whole thing it was like a
you know he broke into a car dealership
and
he's he was essentially stealing keys he
was accused of stealing keys as well as
a jacket
he's they he gets held by the owner then
they chase him out then the whole
sort of bulk of people hear about this
they tear down the street
my brother and i are standing right
there as this is all going on we were
just like interviewing some guy when it
when
we turned the mob is just charging up
the street at us
and and you know looks like what do we
do i said start running i guess you know
see what's going on keep filming right
and and so we do we keep filming they
knock down the fence they get in the guy
bolts he gets away
but in this guy being who he is he comes
back
later trying to like act as if he's part
of the group
like hey guys what's going on and
meanwhile the son of the dealer owner is
is right there
saying hey you're wearing my dad's
jacket you're you're clearly the guy
who who changes rob jack yeah you know
the um retired nypd guy in a class i was
in once said you know
in the intel community who said like you
know most of the people that that you
know resort to crime aren't necessarily
the smartest people to begin with so
you know and he was like trying to give
like sell people chips out of a bag
it's like a backpack so they start
chasing him again once they identify him
they grab him they hold him up and rat
so razz right sort of the rasimone the
warlord razz right is there at this
point he
he [ __ ] and locks right in front of me
and starts running down the street after
this guy with the son
of uh the car dealer who has an ar-15
and kit they're chasing this guy they
grip him up they have him
up on the hood of a car and then the
question comes
right you know open your bag and and you
know in the back of my head i'm thinking
on who's authority right right on whose
authority do i open this force
they exercise the authority of force
they exert over others this is this is
where warlords come from
this is lord of the flies this is hobbs
nasty life is nasty british and short
right you he wins
every time because they had to resort to
that immediately
so there are a lot of people who might
say they're anarchists or whatever they
wear all black they go and smash things
but it's also important to realize some
of these people don't have a political
ideology
you know we we assume if they're there
with antifa
then they must share their beliefs a lot
of them are just
smashing for the sake of smashing and if
you talk to them they won't tell
they won't understand any concept of of
political philosophy or anything
so we get into this a little bit in the
book as well and i talk about
eric hoffer who's sort of the you know
the working class philosopher of the
1950s
he wrote this book called true believers
and he's talking about this this
situation you know it
when you have this sort of mass of you
know basically disenfranchised
youth typically male who
are denied meaningful work who are
denied meaningful access to society or
at least the perception of denied
meaningful access to society
right you get all these tensions that
will inherently bubble up and they will
go go into something and
in some cases they know it go they go
into religion in some cases they'll go
into
uh you know this you know you could look
at stuff that's going on right now
obviously hoffer didn't talk about this
but like keto or crossfit or some of
these different things
but for other people you know they want
to just be the guys who are going out
drinking and getting into fights and so
here's the thing if you're looking at
the situation now
and even you know not consciously making
this decision but
if the media is telling you well if you
join this drinking and fighting group
you'll be prosecuted
but if you join this one you'll be free
to go celebrated
applauded and if something happens you
know you'll either get a slap on the
wrist or the charges will be dropped
which one are you going to join
that's why we see that there's that
video out of portland where some random
kid runs up and punts a guy in the head
that kid doesn't have a political
ideology that guy can't tell you
anything about
that's like from 2016 right no no no
this was uh uh the punt in the head i
think was 2018. oh okay yeah
i'm pretty sure it's 2018. a guy is
running from the group of antifa and
then he
they push him he falls and the kid runs
up and then full just
punts his head that kid doesn't believe
anything most of those people there
the mob that chases random people
doesn't believe anything
so these are just useful idiots just
bodies for
authoritarian communists the people who
are willing to use violence to get their
way
because i'll put it this way the people
you've you've met from antifa
on a polit on a political ideology do
they believe in respecting your right to
liberty
absolutely not right they believe that
they should dictate how you live and how
everyone else should live
libertarian left hey man me and my
friends are going to do our thing and
cooperate
and you do your thing it doesn't scale
you can't have 10
000 no you can't but you can't you can't
have a free market
a libertarian right would can scale up
infinitely so this is this is the
problem that that lenin ran into
in the soviet union and you see i'm
looking for this bolshevik revolution
i'm looking for this worker revolution
what is wrong with these workers they're
just not revolting i don't understand
why won't these why do they just keep
going to their jobs and and working
we need to come up with well we'll
perhaps you know the theory can't be
wrong it's just we're just missing an
element yes that's what it is
we need a you know a group to
lead the workers yes that's what it is
and we'll call it the
of course the revolutionary vanguard
will be the
and that'll be us of course because
we're not stuck in these menial jobs
while we will be the vanguard to to lead
the workers
in their uprising again to
their best uses because we know what's
best for them that's and that's len
that's where that's
where it becomes goes from marxism to
marxist leninism
so lenin adds this idea of the vanguard
of the proletariat and that becomes the
bolsheviks
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time